- Well that's, that's insanity.
- That's insanity?
- That's insane.
Just so everybody understands it again,
understanding the demo of this
and a lot of the undertones
that we're talking about,
that is everything.
(chill music)
From the top 12 for a week.
I mean I went on
livestream for eight hours
22 months ago and could barely break
like number 60 and 70 for Ask Gary V.
And I've done, I've just done so,
it's been a totally
different campaign, you know?
It's just so different.
And I mean, I just think
it's coming over very viral.
I really really really really do.
I also genuinely believe,
many more so than any book
since Crush It, if you
give this to your kid,
your aunt, your college roommate,
your coworker, this book, I
can see you shaking your head
right now.
- [Woman] I completely agree.
It's gonna help so many people.
- Right? It's cool right.
- [Woman] I'm gonna like
get it for my friends
who like wanna do it.
- Seriously?
- [Woman] Yeah, for sure.
- So, I just am feeling,
I just think it's got it like that.
It's got it like that.
Crush It's nine years ago today,
I get five emails, I
read Crush It yesterday,
it blew my mind, it changed my life,
and I'm like God.
It's talking about outdated platforms
and outdated strategies.
Crushing It is going to be probably
my bestselling book ever.
Like I can just see it already.
Just doing way too well organically.
I think it's gonna motivate.
But way more importantly, I
think it's gonna show people
other people that have done it,
and more importantly, it's
gonna teach them how to do it
per platform, which platform,
it would mean the world to me
if you spread some love today
and picked up some copies.
What up, my man?
- I started documenting my shit,
and then once I started documenting it,
that shit blew up.
Like I get people DMing me now,
they're like, oh dude, what
you dropped was so fire,
I'm like, really, I just filmed some dude
that wanted some advice.
And just, you know what I mean?
But then so many people can
relate to the real shit.
- 100%.
- Yeah.
- The only vulnerability
one has to documenting
like this early in the
process is faking the funk.
Like all you have to
do is speak the truth,
and you win.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Like too many kids,
especially young, like you guys,
you know, like there's a sense of like
wanting to be the expert
that I think hurts kids.
Like, but if you just speak like yo
I'm just trying to figure this out, too.
Or, I have figured out
this part, you know?
This documenting thing is 100% right.
The only thing that's
wrong that I see kids doing
is try to act tough.
- Yeah.
- AKA like talking about shit
they've never experienced.
- Exactly. So from like
18 to 19 and a half,
I tried everything, I worked
13 jobs in that time span.
And then my mom was like,
my mom was kinda of like,
your son's a fucking loser,
you know what I'm saying? It's funny.
- I think all of what is going on with me
is not letting anybody's POV on me
have any impact whatsoever.
Other people's opinions is the
worst fucking thing on earth.
The fact that somebody
with an anonymous account,
leave a comment under Instagram
and it hurts your feelings for a day
is fucking ridiculous.
Be in a cocoon, speak to
yourself only about yourself
and run the fucking marathon
cause life's not a sprint.
- That's gangster, son.
- What up family. Orlando, what up?
People making real moves.
Make yours now. One life.
Don't fucking waste it.
Do your thing, man. Long game.
Only thing that you can get caught up in,
it's so cliche, don't,
the one thing that is.
That makes me different.
Don't embellish. Don't just stay, like.
People are gonna react to
your charisma, you got it.
The only thing that gets
caught up is when the momentum
gets going.
You can become a character show yourself.
Stay disciplined.
- Yeah.
- Understand?
- Yeah. Totally.
- You caught that little spot.
You caught that little scene
through the window, huh?
- [Woman] Yep.
- Good job. Right, cause it's real.
- How's it going? Congratulations.
- Thank you brother.
- Those are amazing.
- Right?
- Are those the ones that
are made like 600 though?
- Dude it's just so real.
Thank you.
Guys, it hasn't started.
It's so much bigger than people realize.
Like if you don't have
a sense of the streets,
you're not going to be relevant period
over the next 20, 30 years.
Because that's what the internet has.
It's scale of the micro becomes the macro.
Real simple, let me give
you a couple analogies.
This last year was the worst
year for the biggest artist
in the world.
Because the machine can't help
Katy Perry as much anymore.
Because people are dying the
death of a thousand cuts.
Because Tierra Whack's
gonna get her listens.
Because Killie's gonna get listens.
Cause Lil Xan's gonna get listens.
Cause Gunna is gonna get listens.
- Alternatives.
- It just scale of alternatives.
This isn't about an
alternative college station
running some whacks.
This is Soundcloud and
Spotify are big. Like scale.
Like fucking MTV 84 scale.
And that changes everything.
Oh shit!
This is, this guys, everything,
this guy's my number one.
- Me too!
- He's the only person I didn't meet
that I can't like, I can't think of,
I might go to his fucking tombstone.
(chill music)
Just rolled some high
97. E bro and the crew.
That was a real good session.
You know, really really
really, we'll link up
to the internet version
of this in the vlog.
Check it. Feeling good.
Feeling good today.
Just feeling incredible.
Thank you guys so much for the support.
Can't thank you guys
enough. Feeling incredible.
Are they, they are, like for the ...
I got scared. I don't
know why I got scared.
That's awesome. The C is backwards.
Thanks guys, that's very nice.
Davin, you couldn't
flip. You couldn't flip?
You couldn't flip? That's
so awesome. Thanks guys.
You can't lose when you're the truth.
I mean, it's just hard to lose.
Oh, you want the shot?
Maribelle, how many copies
of Crushing It did you buy?
Don't lie.
(beep)
- [Man] What just happened?
Maribelle, what did you say? Or not say.
- [Woman] You said be honest.
- That's what, you know I
hate the fucking Giants,
but that's a great sweater.
Alex, pull up number three.
Number three in the world. Three.
- [Woman] We did it.
- JD, how many books did you buy?
Tell the truth, don't lie.
- None yet, but I'm gonna buy one.
- So dead. So dead. I feel
like I'm those fainting lambs.
- I think we should just say.
This is posted. That's incredible.
- How cool is that?
- But I love the mix
too, it's not too bold.
Like it's enough.
Tyler said that was in the inside.
- Even though, even though
it hasn't happened yet.
- Katy, and then we shoot it ...
- This been, I was speaking with her about
what I'm trying to do and
grow and just understanding
like how to slowly put
something special together.
And she said, hey you know,
this would be the perfect person
for you to meet and just
kind of shake hands with.
- Good to know.
- And get to know and know for
advice and stuff like that so
- So you know, about two years ago,
my brother left this
company and we started
a sports representation business.
So I've gotten real educated about.
I'm really friendly, Brandon.
And like, always been
friends with players,
cause I'm such a die hard Jets fan.
And but I got real educated the last year.
And like there's so much opportunity
and guys are either not motivated,
they're too romantic
and think they're gonna
go to the hall of fame
and that's where all
the money's gonna come from.
And more importantly,
the agents and managers
are just not after your
panini sports car deal
or your sneaker deal,
they're not doing anything.
And so, but the opportunity,
while you're an NFL player
there's so much leverage.
So, yeah, I've got a much,
I've always had a perspective.
But I got a real perspective now.
So I'm thrilled to answer.
I mean I think, what I think is, look,
a million people ask to meet with me.
And like if Whitney asked
me I would meet with anybody
but and active athlete has leverage.
Nothing else to say.
- [Man] Right. Use it.
- Straight up. Like every single person
that wants to meet, like
everybody that's a fan
of the team you're on at the
moment is an opportunity.
I'll meet with the,
I will meet with Lachlan
Edwards right now,
the punter of the Jets, in two seconds.
An A list business
person, I may never meet,
cause I'm busy.
That's leverage.
It's very powerful.
The biggest thing I can tell you
is you can meet a lot more
people than you think.
And that's what I would figure out.
Like I'd be living on Twitter,
searching my team's name
and being like oh that guys CO of this.
And he's going crazy about my team.
Let me just like this post.
Like, one of, when any
Jet player interacts
with anything I do, I
get practice squad guys.
Die hard fandom is a real arbitrage.
It's the number one thing
athletes should be doing right now
is searching their team.
Forget about, you know, I mean listen,
if you're a super athlete,
and everybody knows,
so you are and it's different.
But like, there's a lot of die hards.
Who really know who their left hackle is.
Who really know who their gunners are.
You know?
And I sit with two guys at the Jet game
that sit in front of me,
these guys made real economics
being at Goldman Sachs.
Like, if a Jets corner hit him up
and was like yo.
So that's number one.
That's the number one piece of advice.
Because people are gonna be,
Wendy's advice was right.
I'm gonna have a much bigger
impact on your business empire
or people like me.
It's always people. So.
But it's the leverage.
While you got that shield.
- [Man] Use it.
- Yes.
And when you're lucky enough
to be in the right markets,
there's people.
- [Man] Right.
- So tell us about the book quickly.
Cause I know we have to
do something else next.
For everybody who's watching,
it's very simple.
I think that the internet
is grossly underrated.
And that it blows my mind that if you make
$74,000 year doing
something you don't love
that you can make $67,000
a year or $83,000 a year
literally being the foremost
expert about bee keeping,
or running at 6am, or gardening peppers,
or selling real estate,
or the town on Monclair.
Like I am blown away
by the long tail financial opportunities
and then doing something
that you, like look.
The great, you know, we won life.
Because, forget about the family stuff,
which is the real part.
The second part is just you
work a lot of your life.
Like Americans work a lot.
Like you don't even want, friends,
you do not actually
wanna put down on paper
what percentage of your
life is actually at work.
A lot.
And you have to love
it, from my perspective,
in the internet age.
And this is about why, the
mentality of all the things
that they're fearful of,
which is their parents judgment,
college debt, your spouses point of view,
why you aren't doing this,
you're lazy, or you like
watching entire seasons
of The Crown but
complaining about your job.
All the mental stuff.
- So why are we number three?
What did you do to get this number three?
- I built a brand.
Podcast nation what is up.
It's me, Gary, a very exciting day for me
that we're recording this right now
as the book is being launched,
it's launch day, it's
going extremely well.
And I wanna first start and say thank you
to all of you that are supporting.
I really really really do appreciate it.
But more importantly,
we're doing our second pod sessions.
- What is something, like
one story, one person,
one aspect, of Crushing It,
that you want people to hear
what something, maybe
they're on the fence.
Why do I need this book?
What's something you hear from it?
- Yeah, honestly, I'm
less worried about people
like getting the book,
like go to the library,
steal it on like a BitTorrent,
I really just want you
to read it.
Like, I'm really, I mean it.
Like, listen, I want you to
buy a thousand copies too.
Like I'm all over the place on that.
That part doesn't excite me.
What excites me is, I wrote
this book as much for you,
who I think is very advanced,
as I did for somebody's
who's never done anything
on the internet.
Meaning, for somebody's who's never done,
it's like time to try.
Like just make a one minute to
the camera on your Instagram
post about your thoughts on X.
Period. E sports. WWE. Like, I don't care.
Jelly shoes from the 80's.
Like it's time.
Number two. And this is really for you,
like you don't even know how I feel
about you doing this podcast.
I have no idea how much
or how little impact
I have on you doing this podcast.
- You had an impact.
- I thought so, because I'm
pushing all of you so hard
to do voice more than anybody.
And I know you're gonna win.
You're about to build
a much bigger audience
because a lot of people
wanna watch your videos
but they're busy.
And now that when they're
on their treadmill,
or going to work,
they're gonna listen to this.
And they would have never watched this.
It's a big deal.
So for me, I wrote this book
because I can't believe,
after where I was, even
when you and I met.
Where I was on the pedestal
of leadership on this genre
where I've gone in the last 15 months
is to a totally different plane.
I'm in a totally different plane.
15 months ago, I would
be noticed on the streets
once every two or three days for a selfie.
If I'm outside for a minute,
I'm taking 34 selfies a day.
I'm starting to get weird
and kind of weirdly like
and I love it.
I love the interaction.
- Perspective, two years ago,
we were almost at the
same subscriber count
around 100,000.
And now Gary is past a million. Congrats.
- Thank you.
- Crushing it.
- But you know what's
even more interesting?
And I think this is why
I think you're special.
I think you're gonna win because you
have something very real to say
and you're coming from a good place.
Like to me, I appreciate that,
and metrics have some
eluding to what's going on.
But I'm much more, I look
at metrics as width, right?
Like how many. But depth.
What makes me still spend time with you
is I think you have depth.
I have depth.
Like I don't think I'll ever, again,
it was kind of like the
Bezos and Zuckerberg thing.
I don't think I'll ever
have the most points.
The most followers, like the most money,
but depth I think I have a shot.
Can somebody play some?
She's on my livestream and
she's going to be fucking
Lauryn Hill 3.0.
You better fucking download
it that Tierra Whack.
Seth, don't bullshit.
I want all Tierra Whack music 24/7,
she's my favorite person on Earth.
Did you see her? Have you listened, Emily?
- I haven't listened but see she's ...
- She's so talented.
I want you to listen right now.
- [Man] That songs really good.
- That songs really good, right?
Like the whole depth, like
she's so fucking brilliant.
I can't wait.
I can't wait for 36 months from now.
It feels like Instagram and Twitter,
that's what I'm doing now with artists.
I'm about to do it with soccer too.
I've decided I'm gonna penetrate
European soccer culture.
- [Woman] No shit.
- I might go to World Cup.
I think I'm going to World Cup.
I'm going to Russia.
Alex, look at my calendar.
Let's take it at the beginning.
Like what happened from the beginning?
- Well, we just, we did one of them things
to where he blew up on the tunnel.
You know, people that do skits,
their more like oh the
duplication will apply
so you can't do it again.
So we went on and we just did it again.
The video went viral.
A lot of celebrities got a hold of it.
And they were just
like, let's do it again.
- [Gary] What were you doing before that?
- I was doing regular
skits. Regular skits.
But then I fell into doing raw videos.
Soon a whole clip through.
Doing stuff that it just looked.
- [Gary] When Vine was popping?
- When Vine was popping, yeah,
but then Vine fell off on Vine.
I had my few followers on Instagram.
He was just dancing.
He ain't had no Instagram, so he was like,
you wanna do videos,
so we did a few skits together,
it didn't go no further than Louisiana.
But then we just gave up on doing skits,
and we just started shooting raw comedy.
Just being ourselves.
It took off.
- Truth always fucking wins.
So, it's a real brain twist, like,
here's where we got lucky
and where we got fucked up.
The shit we put on a pedestal isn't cool.
It's not as good as we think.
And we're in the tail end.
You two are gonna walk into this office
its gonna be Sammy and
Ricky in three years
and this is gonna be out
of their mouth. Done.
You're like the, by the way, you guys
are the last frontier of
even considering that model.
It's just over.
Make your own fucking Netflix documentary.
Go fucking email Hulu
right now and be like,
yo, we're gonna make a
fucking Chapelle Show for you.
Pay us, and they'll be like okay.
- We're Jennings, bitch. We just want it.
- It's weird, man. It's
really really weird.
People need content. You guys have talent.
If you're so talented,
you got an audience,
like, you don't need
anybody in the middle.
Like you're in a much better spot
then literally than Chapelle.
You understand why?
You haven't done anything where anybody
has any control over anything you do.
But you have audience.
You have to understand
why people signed before.
They didn't have an audience.
You guys are too young.
You're taking shit for granted.
You guys have more people
watching one of your skits
than most cable TV shows have viewers.
The money hasn't flowed properly yet.
But it will.
How'd it all go down?
Give me the origin story.
- Started in high school.
The primary thing was a blog, you know,
did videos on the side.
- Like a Tumblr blog or a WordPress or ...
- Like a WordPress.
- And what was it called?
- Lyric lemonade.
- Right from the get.
- Yeah, right from the get go.
- And what was the first premise of it?
- The blog.
- Meaning like, what was the blog about?
- Oh, I'm sorry.
Coming home every day after school
and just writing articles
on new local Chicago
hip hop music.
And I was living about an hour
and a half outside the city.
You know, did that through high school.
Built the brand around
my friends in school.
Went out to the city
every weekend, you know,
passing out stickers,
throwing small little events
with what I could.
Moved to the city after I
graduated college, at DuPaul.
Was just expending
everything. Going to school.
- It was always about that.
- Yeah, and then.
- What the first good moment?
- First good moment?
Just like selling out,
I think, like the venues
in Chicago that I went to,
and just like kind of
building up the ladder,
like I wonder if I can won this one,
and then a couple of months later,
we signed out those venues.
- And you were curating the talent?
- Yeah. We did lyric lemonade shows
and curate the talent.
Just putting together a good show.
- Who were you putting on?
- I put Lil Uzi Vert's
first show in Chicago ever.
My sophomore year of college.
It sold out. And like after that,
I think in terms of shows, you know.
- Everything skyrocketed
so fast after that.
- Here's what I would say.
Too many people rush to switch.
I like your general energy
of not switching too early.
Just keep it. You're 21.
The longer you can just keep
doing it about them, you win.
But yeah, man, like your
ability with the kind of things
I'm hearing and I gotta
do a little more homework.
I mean I know about it
but like, excuse me,
your ability to build the
Coachella of like this genre
is real. That's real fucking business.
You can do anything.
It's all about attention.
It just comes down to you.
- Right.
- I said in the last meeting,
some people wanna make 5
million and go to Jamaica
smoke weed for the rest of their life.
And some people wanna build empires.
Like, I don't know, and then
everything in between, right.
- Last two questions.
Worst advice you've ever given.
- I'm sorry?
- Worst advice you've ever given.
- The worst advice I've ever given.
- When you look back on it you think,
you know what, I didn't know enough then.
Whatever it is.
- I probably in my 20's and 30's, 20's,
in my 20's, I assume,
and I don't remember.
You wanna hear something insane?
For most of my life, probably
the first 15 years of my life
I didn't give any advice.
Which is weird cause
I'm like spitting advice
all the time now.
I just did it.
Cause I didn't think
I had the audacity to.
I think that, if I did give advice,
it would have been more
counseling than advice.
And I probably, if I gave bad advice,
it was me not understanding
that I was unique,
and I was trying to give my
advice that worked for me,
I think what I've gotten really good at
is learning the person
and giving them advice
based on them and making it contextual,
and that's why I'm very
careful, I speak in absolute,
but I always try to be
contradiction to myself
back to Mohan's question.
Of like, but that's me.
- Yes.
- Self awareness, bro.
Fucking self awareness.
You wanna talk about
the other super power?
Self awareness. Self
awareness, my friends.